GAMEFF TO THE LEFT OF
IGOR SHESTERKIN.
NO GOAL.ACT
THIS PUCK GOING INTO THE NET.
THIS IS A GOOD GOAL. BRYCE ALLUE
OVERTIME BUT NEVER PLAYED WITH A
LEAD.
HERE I
THE ARM OF DOMINGUE AND RIGHT UP
UNDERNEATH THE!
IT GOT B.
>> Bryce: THE WEIGHT BEHINO CON
CARTER AND NOW RODRIGUES SCORESE
FAR R
PLAY A LOT, COVERING THE -- THIS
IS THE BEST I HAVEAND SCHNEIDER
IT, SHOT PETRANO.
ZIBANEJAD DIDN'T KEEP IT IN T F
HERE OCCUPIES MATHESON IN THE
FRFR THE PUCK OUT TO
STROME.
NOW FOX.
FAR SIDE FOR PANARINS TOP BY DO!
REBOUND.
SCORE!
E NET OFF.
BATTED THE P PWE
NEED 200 FOOT CLEAR.
THEY GOT DO A BETTER JOB.
IF THEY DUMP IT INPITTSBURGH OF.
SHOOTS FOR THE EMPTY NET.Y BACKI
CROSBY MOVING UP ON THE ALL-TIME
PLAYOFF POINTS LISIS